foreign
Goldsboro North Carolina what's up Tyrus
hey John how you doing I'm good what's
up man
uh definitely emphasize with her as well
as what she's going through with her
husband because I was that guy and then
that guy oh sweet but we're calling
about we're on the other side of it oh
awesome to get out of it the whole time
I was talking to her I kept thinking man
I want to talk to her husband and then
you called so way to go yeah yeah
so what's up let's do this okay so
actually I was referred to you
thankfully I've listened to your podcast
and thoroughly enjoy it but I had called
today about a financial question and I
don't have a financial problem according
to everybody I've got a lot of other
stuff going on all right let's unpack it
I'm angry naturally
uh very angry person
um at what trying to
stuff in the past that I want to be able
to get over what since it's having kids
what name it
we're mostly directed towards my mother
and father what what
I know I don't want to like you know
Gaslight anybody that's why I'm I'm
trying to be careful so I don't want to
be who my father was which was a very
angry person at whatever he was angry at
he took it out on us okay
and I met my wife God bless her
um a little over two years ago she had
four children from her previous marriage
and we had an eight-month-old of her own
so a lot of children love them a lot of
children
hey hold on that's a million kids
angry guy you're gonna meet I just think
anger's like a waste of most of my
energy
yeah five kids would make me probably
just an angry guy from eight months to
15 so quite a and I'm 25 so I'm still a
child myself at a lot of times you're 25
yes
this is all I mean this is top five my
favorite calls ever already keep going
this is just good okay all right all
right boost my ego a little bit please
break it down
um so
I've heard a lot you talk a lot about
secrets and how they kill you yep
and it kind of not kind of it frustrates
me because I was known in my family and
like braggingly braggadociously the
steel trap of the family if you have a
secret come to Tyrus nobody will ever
find out
and it's
listening to you say it kills kills you
like I forced myself to basically become
a robot because
I didn't have I'd never made enough time
to really look at myself and care about
myself it was always
bringing on other people's stuff
and what are you carrying that you don't
want to carry anymore
uh everybody's Secrets my own secrets
that I'm not even like what I just What
secrets
something was done to me at a very young
age that was not okay and she's sexually
abused yes okay listen I'm gonna be
super clear okay
your anger that cloud that swirl
lives and breathes ambiguous language
it lives and breathes these things and
these feelings and these other things
and these other things
one of the straightest paths through all
of this BS is naming stuff
that guy sexually abused me
that woman cheated on me you see what
I'm saying yeah it just shines a light
on all of it clears that fog out and now
we have something we can actually direct
ourselves at we don't do our bodies
don't let us do that because it's scared
rightfully so well it's it's messed up
because I'm not even scared for
people finding out what happened to me I
just don't want anybody getting in
trouble because it was years ago like it
sounds messed up I know but it's like
what good comes out from anybody knowing
what happened uh Hey listen
freedom
sleeping all night
I don't sleep I know you don't because
your body's still on 24 7 365 alert
watch
that's exactly right you know why
because your body remembers hate we
remember what it's like to be that age
remember what happens
stay extra vigilant
and then your brain takes up every bit
of emotional margin you have
so that eight-month-old does
eight-month-old stuff like spit up and
you lose your damn mind is that right
well that's so much that she's actually
perfect in my eyes you know what I mean
no no they spill juice and I'm like son
of them exactly exactly yes so here's
what I'm gonna tell you what's going to
come out of it peace
your body put a GPS pin in that pain
and it has continued to beep on that pin
until you deal with it
until you let your body know
I'm a 25 year old father of five now I'm
in the driver's seat
you don't have to protect me anymore
because I'm not seven anymore I'm not 12
anymore
I'm not the family baggage keeper
anymore
all anger does man is it points us our
it's our bodies just pointing us towards
something we care about
and my guess is you really care deeply
about uh kids being safe
100 and you really care deeply about
people feeling loved
the challenge is you don't have the
tools on how to keep kids safe because
you're too busy keeping yourself safe
very fair it's not a moral judgment
that's a physiological judgment
you want to show people deep love and
you've never even seen that happen
because your parents are too busy saying
hey carry this for me carry this for me
carry this for me
and they used you like a pack mule
foreign
you should have been a little boy having
a good time
it doesn't matter it absolutely doesn't
matter
it's how is my body responding in the
present one of the things we know about
memory is that it's it's pretty faulty
it's pretty faulty
um
what's important and this is from Peter
Dr Peter Levine's work this is from
vandercook's work what's really
important is less about the specifics
the minute details of something that
happened in our past
it's one of those memories do to our
bodies in the present
okay
[Music]
so here's a good example let's say when
I first got married my wife got in my
face and screamed and yelled
that's that's how what I remember 20
years later she planted her finger in my
face and screamed it yelled and told me
that I sucked at something right
let's say that we go through counseling
for years and by the way if you know my
wife she's I would never she would never
do that she would just stab me in my
sleep she would never yell at my face
um so let's say that 20 years later our
marriage is really good
and we've been through therapy together
we have two kids or three kids together
we have reconciled and we have one of
the best marriages ever
and then I do something I forget to pick
up my shoes and she looks up and just
that anger flashes
and my body instantly goes back to that
moment she was pointing in my face
now I could say remember that you've
been doing this our whole marriage
you're screaming and yelling at me and
she would say dude I didn't I never even
did that
I got mad once I never screamed and
yelled at whatever happened doesn't
matter what happens is my body's
responding right now am I safe yeah I'm
safe
I'm safe now
and I'm gonna take a big deep breath I'm
gonna hold it for a count of four or six
I'm gonna exhale it I'm gonna say these
words inside my mind or out loud
my body's trying to take care of me and
keep me safe I'm good
I'm gonna practice that see what I'm
saying
yeah I've actually because I'm horrible
about going on tangents hey quit talking
crap hey you're my friend quit talking
crap about yourself you talk about
yourself so bad
yeah it's self-talk's horrible it is
yeah I'm trying literally my number one
question I've got written here how to
rewire your brain to be
because it's I'd love to be in better
shape I'd love to not be angry I love
but in those moments the what I've done
before is just suppressed everything and
been a doormat like yeah like you said
you're too quick to forgive because I
didn't want to deal with it I was just
like yeah whatever I don't care steal
from me whatever you weren't forgiving
you just open the door
yeah
forgiveness says I walk out on my front
porch and say
y'all stolen from me in the past you'll
have taken the most precious thing for
me which was my innocence you all did
that I'm not carrying that crap for
y'all anymore I'm setting it down
and you are not welcome in my home and
you walk inside your house and you lock
the door
what you've done is you walk down the
front porch and said hey
I'm just not going to think about y'all
anymore the front door and the back door
wide open
yeah right and you let them ransack the
place and that's not forgiveness that's
avoidance
yeah
okay
so here's the uh
here's where we start
and let me paint you a broader picture
we live in a culture that would tell you
just set some goals
instead of weight loss goal and crush it
and kill it and set a financial goal and
dominate that good right
um
whenever you feel angry just flex and
stop being angry like that's that's how
we approach it and that's in there it's
stupid it's a waste of energy and a
waste of time you burn out that's right
your willpower is much less powerful
than your systems
okay
we're going to start with identity
so what I want you to do today is to go
to like Michael's or or Home Depot or
someplace and either get like a really
nice piece of plywood or get a nice
um piece of cardstock or something
and somewhere in your home I want you to
hang it up and I want you to write on it
with a with a permanent marker and is
nicer lettering as you can do
I am a man who
honors and loves my family
I am a man who
is in control of his emotions
I am a man who is a good Steward of my
body
I am a man who will
own what my parents did
and never repeat it again what we're
going to do is we're going to set
identity statements this is who I am
and then we're going to go back fill
those identities with some actions
they're going to make those things
possible with some systems they're going
to make that possible okay
right and let me just preface this
because I know that it was not my
parents I know that they I I I just want
to get that out there in case anybody
hears my parents listen listen
I just wanted everybody hold on
you still think you are responsible for
the adults in your life
you are not
I don't care who it was
you're not responsible for how your
parents feel not one time did you tell
me that it was them
and you're just I know I know I just
heard you say what they did I didn't
want you to think no I I get that
but I also want you to know you are not
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in your life that's their
job
okay and if if your parents listen to
this and they go bananas we never do you
have to say I never said you did
they will possibly if they don't know be
devastated
that their kid was hurt like that and
they didn't know or they did know about
it and they didn't know how to respond
and so they pretended it never happened
so that's where that's why I'm so angry
hey and you damn well should be
because if they did know
that's exactly worth it have you ever
asked them
I don't that's why I asked about how do
you know
I was six at the time okay seven so it's
weird that I remember stuff from four
years old and I don't it's like it
happened and then black
so I don't know if they know I don't
know if they don't know but so listen if
they did know uh to be fair I don't have
a relationship with them okay so it may
be as I was supposed to be my next
question what's your relationship like
with him if you don't talk to them if
they're out of your life then a
conversation with them is of no value
yeah okay
um that's you just running up in lobbing
grenades at them if they're out of your
life okay
if you have to reconcile the fact that
you were sexually abused and your
parents may have known about it and they
chose nothing
that I I can't think of something more
Justified to be angry about
and it's ruined all of my relationships
no it hasn't no it happens you have I
have correct okay I can't it's been hard
so hard to trust people and not be yes
I've just only become vulnerable with my
wife recently good good hey and I would
like hear me honor that man
so good you are 15 years ahead of me
dude before I learned that kind of
vulnerability you were way ahead of the
game
yeah okay I'm proud of you that's hard
man it's real real hard saying things
out loud
um
but I don't want you to start blaming
the anger for things because you've got
choices
that's true okay absolutely and moving
forward I want us to practice man
you are trying to engage in something
that you've never seen done you've had
somebody describe the game of baseball
to you
and then somebody handed you a bat and
said go play and you're like okay some
guy on a hill is gonna throw a ball at
me and I'm gonna hit it with a stick
okay and then I gotta run where where am
I running right right see what I'm
saying you are figuring out what true
honest vulnerable connected accountable
parenting looks like in real time and
you've never seen it actually done
give yourself some Grace okay
okay
it's gonna be hard oh by the way you're
dealing with four people who've got a
different dad
all right
that's hard too
yeah you know what we should put on top
of that you know we should dump on top
of that an infant that sounds cool
and a dog that sits in the house all the
time hey why not let's have a dog
let's see if we can come up with any
other thing to ruin our sex life and our
intimacy and our financial life like
right you know what I'm saying you're in
it dude you are in it in your eyeballs
yeah
I heard the great Terry reel one of the
most incredible therapists ever I think
foreign
he said that he recommends people who
are struggling with anger
to carry around a picture of their mom
and dad
and put in their wallet
and every time or put on your phone and
every time you're about to unleash on
one of your kids or on your wife
pull out your phone look at that picture
no no I'm kidding pull out that phone
and look at him and say hey Mom and Dad
this one's for you
all right I'm gonna piss on my kids for
you
I'm here to honor you
and he reports that
people stop their angry outbursts
immediately and they never pick him up
again
yeah what we're looking for is a gap
between stimulus and response okay
that impulse to yell and the actual
yelling yourself the actual yelling
itself
if you can
put Even a Splinter of a wedge in
between those two things you got a shot
okay
okay I can't recommend enough
can't recommend enough that you need to
call somebody and go talk to somebody
okay
because not only do you have the abuse
in the background the potential parental
involvement and all that mess
but you probably have a wake of people
behind you that you've hurt over the
years out of your own pain is that fair
but that's putting it lightly and that
pain creates great guilt which turns
into great shame which then eats those
secrets and you see how this thing turns
into a loop
yep and then here's this is the
important part
if you don't deal with this
you are making a conscious choice to
hand this off to those five kids
and that's why I'm calling like I don't
I don't want to be
the father that they're scared to say
there you go hey Dad I got drunk can you
come pick me up or if I messed up can
you help me I didn't have that that's
right and what that's going to look like
ultimately is
um I want to be I want I don't want to
be that dead either
so this morning I got up
before I usually get up to get my
workout in
so that then I could get my whatever
thinking or praying or writing time
whatever nonsense I do in the mornings
so that I could have breakfast with my
12 year old
every Tuesday morning
so that one day in four or five or six
years he's gonna find himself in a mess
and he's going to know not because I
said something
but because I showed up over and over
and over
I'm planting seeds and the fruit's not
going to be I'm not going to taste that
for years
see what I'm saying
yeah I don't mind if they do the 12 year
old hate I hate you and stomp upstairs
but when they're 30 I don't I won't come
to call me that's right that's right and
they're going to learn how to call you
by you calling them
and they're going to learn how to reach
out to you
by you
reaching out to them
and they're going to learn how to treat
women by how you treat their mother
and they're going to learn how to tip
and honor the waitress even when the
food sucks because of how you do it
and they're going to learn how to say
hey I'm really spun up right now I'm
gonna take a walk around the house give
me 30 minutes and then we'll have this
conversation
okay yeah hear me say this you get to
change everything
and I'm sick to my stomach that somebody
hurt you when you were young
if you hear nothing else brother hear me
say that shouldn't happen and I'm sorry
and I'm sorry that there was no adults
there to protect you and I'm sorry there
was no adults there to comfort you
you deserved better than that
I appreciate that okay
and now everything moving forward is a
choice
I'm gonna give you a copy of own your
past change your future okay my latest
book it's going to walk you through it
I'm gonna send it to you for free I'm
also gonna send you four or five decks
of the questions for humans here's what
those are
I actually talked to my wife about that
like 10 minutes before I got on the call
you know what they are but let me tell
you what they really are
they are tools for
dads to talk to their kids
to teach fathers how to have
conversations with their children well
that's the best thing you've said or
given to me not not to downplay anything
else but thank you that's what I need
cool
because you're not gonna have to stand
there awkwardly at your kids you're
gonna be able to take that 15 year old
out and you're gonna have these cards
you'll be like all right we're gonna I'm
gonna ask you these questions you ask me
and I'm you're gonna answer them
honestly
and my son asked me this morning when we
were going through uh math flash cards
he asked me
hey Dad did you how did you do math
you know what I told him
when I was in Middle School son I
cheated like crazy in math
I'm ashamed of it
and I robbed myself of learning how to
do math which made high school math
almost impossible which made Collegiate
and doctoral statistics a nightmare
I'm glad that you have chosen to be a
person of integrity
and I got to honor my son by telling him
the truth about who his dad used to be
and now he knows his dad is a fanatic
about cheating and telling the truth I'm
obsessive about it because I used to be
a lying little thief
you see what I'm saying but those cards
give you an opportunity to have that
conversation without it being weird
right right will you use them if I send
them
absolutely that's awesome awesome so
today here's your homework I'm gonna
send you some stuff for free your
homework is
to go get a board of some sort that's
going to be your identity and tension
it's going to be home based for you
here's who I'm going to become
and then you and your wife man y'all
spend some time backfilling that how do
I get there how do I get to be a guy
that stewards his body I need 35 minutes
in the morning in the garage I'm gonna
go buy two kettlebells at Academy and
I'm gonna just pick or two dumbbells I'm
gonna pick up a workout online
I'm just gonna go for walks for 30
minutes in the morning I'm gonna start
there and maybe two years from now I'll
have a big membership at a CrossFit gym
I'm a start there how do I become a guy
who is less reactive and less angry
foreign
I'm gonna stay off my phone I'm going to
leave this toxic job
I'm going to ask you just a wink when
you feel me getting riled up
I'm gonna go tell my kids hey I'm super
sorry I shouldn't have talked to you
like that and on and on and on
Tyrus I I know one thing
you can do this
and go call counselor brother you
deserve the healing